how do you run the world's largest
election how exactly do you organize the
planets biggest exercise in democracy
India's last national election back in
2009 soar 713 million people eligible to
vote this time around there are eight
hundred and fifteen million people with
access to the ballot why such a big jump
well in there's a young country 23
million of those newly registered voters
have just turned 18 or 19
there are around 8,000 candidates from
more than 1,600 political parties vying
for 543 seats in India's lower house of
parliament called the Lok Sabha voting
takes place in nine separate phases
passing through two dozen distinct
geographic regions in a country this
size it may not be surprising but there
are nine hundred and nineteen thousand
polling stations nationwide where more
than 3.6 million electronic voting
machines will be used more than 7
million officials will help run the
election 120,000 of them security
personnel the government's price tag are
cool six hundred million u.s. dollars
despite all these efforts there may be
some voters who remain disillusioned
with the entire political class in this
vast democracy so for then there's
another first those electronic voting
machines will offer an option beloved by
undecided voters everywhere none of the
above